sur le fond l'europe monétaire a
enregistré je vous le disais aujourd'hui
une avancée décisive avec l'accord
trouvé par les 15 ministres des finances
sur le pacte de stabilité budgétaire
clé de voûte de l'union économique et
monétaire sur place françoise laborde un
petit pas pour les quinze un grand pas
pour le roux il peut être satisfait le
premier ministre irlandais c'est chez
lui à dublin
jacques chirac elle montre hall ont fini
par se mettre d'accord sur le mode
d'emploi de l'euro ce que l'on appelle
le pacte de stabilité et de croissance
le conseil européen a défini une sorte
de règlement de copropriété de l'euro
pour l'après 1999 les pays associés dans
la monnaie unique s'engage à respecter
un certain nombre de critères
économiques
les allemands souhaité que cet
engagement soit très contraignants
assortis de sanctions automatiques
finalement c'est la conception française
en politique du souple qui a été retenu
le conseil est souverain et c'était ça
la préoccupation de la france prenant
induit il n'y a pas d'automatisme c'est
le politique qui décide
maintenant il ne reste plus qu'à évaluer
au printemps 98 c'est à dire dans un an
et demi les performances économiques de
chacun pour savoir qui respecte les
critères de maastricht qui peut rentrer
dans l'euro mais il ne fait aucun doute
ce soir à dublin que le compte à rebours
a commencé et que l'euro verra
effectivement le jour dans deux ans au
plus tard
sauf cataclysme économique